- Yo, Yelo, what up?
- Yo, Chris, you see that video I just sent you?
- Yeah, man, I just seen it
Who is that? He seem like he nice
- Trashaun Willis
That kid can shoot, man
I think I might need you to go out there and check him out
- I’m in, I’m in
- Aight, we about to make this kid’s day
- Yo C, can we stop in Iowa real quick?
[“Dedication” by Nipsey Hussle (feat. Kendrick Lamar) plays]
- Out here in the middle of Iowa, cornfield on cornfield on cornfield
It’s the home of Trashaun Willis
A natural athlete born with only one arm
He went viral for dunking it
And he plays QB
Don’t tell him he’s “disabled,” and do not call him “special”
He’s only a sophomore in high school
And this kid is just getting started
- The first one that got caught on camera was at the middle school
It was, like, third or fourth quarter, and I stole it and then I dunked it
And then you just see the student section going crazy
- So I just asked the dean of students for the security footage
And then I screen-recorded it and posted it on Twitter
- People were just, like, just, I don’t know, it just blew up
- All my friends were, like, boosting me up and stuff
And saying, like, “Oh, you’re famous, blah, blah, blah”
It’s just natural to me, to just go out and do my best
And I guess that just amazes people because I do have one arm
- Trashaun was born with amniotic band syndrome
Which is a band in your amniotic fluid that wraps around something that’s developing
You go through a hundred different emotions
Of, “How is my child going to survive with one arm?”
But there was nothing that he couldn’t do or learn how to do
He was able to learn to ride a bike, zip and button his pants
So when Trashaun’s dunk went viral
I guess it didn’t really surprise me that he could dunk a basketball
- For us to put limitations on Trashaun clearly isn’t fair
I mean, he’s still a big 6’4”-bodied kid
With an incredibly strong lower body that’s got a great vertical jump
- You’re scared, you’re scared, huh?
- He’s out there playing with one hand, and he’s dominating
I mean, there’s times last year I couldn’t take him off the court
Because he was the best player on our team
He’s really good with his outside shot
- My jump shot, I think it’s normal, so I just take my hand and put it on the back
And then I just use my little arm to make sure it doesn’t really fall off
So that’s just what I do
The only adjustments I’d say are, like, dribbling
Most teams try and force me to go to my left
- He’s got, like, this kind of goofy Eurostep that he uses
He can’t crossover. He just can’t do it. So he has a move
Where he just goes behind his back and then catches it on the left side
- It’s times when he was constantly getting the ball stolen from him
He’s trying to figure it out and figure it out
And he just couldn’t
He couldn’t just figure it out, If he just made that one little turn
And turned like this with the ball, he’d just start working it out
Kids come at him, kids really don’t care
They’re competitors as well, you know?
- You know, they’re getting scored on by a kid that only has one arm
They don’t like it
- The one game last year, some kid
I swatted him, and it went out of bounds, and I said, “Get that out of here!”
He’s like, “Shut up, you literally have one arm”
So that just set me off, I went off on him
- He never comes to me and says, “Dad, I can’t get through this”
He admits that stuff is hard, you know, but he never says that he can’t
Usually people that got some kind of,...we give them a pass on “I can’t”
Because we have compassion for them, but I can’t with my son
We look for a victory this week
You know your friends keep coming up to me and say they want you to
They want to still see you at quarterback
- Varsity guys, we need to be ready for practice
Hey, we gotta have a good one, we gotta have a good one today
We’re going to right this ship, alright?
[Students cheer]
- Trashaun is our varsity starting middle linebacker, No. 2 backup QB
He’s really the leader and quarterback of our defense
He’s just a no-excuses kid that always shows up
And gets it done in spite of his handicap
I would consider him to have a physical handicap
I would not consider him disabled because
He is more able than many of the players we have on our team with both arms
- So I go to a second-grade classroom
And I just help kids out with either their math
or reading or setting up their portfolio
Whatever they need help with
So 10, 20, what comes after 20?
- 30?
- There you go
- Trashaun’s awesome, the kids love to have him in our classroom
They love to have him out on the playground, and they look up to him, you know?
He’s a football player, he’s a basketball player
I had Trashaun in second grade, and there was one thing that Trashaun told me
That he couldn’t do and that was tie his shoes, and that was the only thing
- That was pretty hard, I didn’t learn that until, like, second grade
But even then, like, that’s still good for me
- I remember the first time I noticed he tied his shoes
They were tied, he had did it
When we tried to reach down and tie his shoes, he was, like, not having it
So he was going to be OK when he stepped out into school and the world
- Trashaun is living his life the only way he’s ever known, but let’s be real
One arm or two, he’s still got to prove himself every day
On the court, and off
Going viral was legit, but going pro is the focus
- I hope someday that I can play at the highest level, the NBA or football
That’s my ultimate goal, all the way up there
Ever since, like, last football season, I’ve just been looking up to Shaquem Griffin
He has what I have, amniotic band syndrome
Anything is possible, I guess
Like, if he can do it, anyone can do it
I can do it
- For me, you know, playing basketball in the back yard, that was my passion
You know, when I finished my homework, me and my brother went outside
We would play until my mom said it was time to come in and eat dinner
You know, everyone has their own story, you know, and you really don't know
Where somebody’s from until you really go visit them and see what it’s like
For me, it’s just going and basically putting a smile on his face
And let him know that somebody will come to Iowa
You know, and drive past all these cornfields, and give him the time
- His dad know?
Oh, I know
- Whoa, who’s that?
Oh, that’s Chris Paul
Oh, hecks no
- CP!
- Whaaaat?
- I got next. Heard you got some game, huh?
- What’s up, boss?
- What’s up?
- What’s happening? Chris, man
- It’s nice to meet you
- It’s nice to meet you, man
- Nice to meet you
- What’s going on?
- What up?
- Ain’t nothin, you alright?
- I seen the video of you dunking and everything
- Uh-huh
- Huh? What you mean “uh-huh?” Now you shy? Now you shy?
- Yeah, it’s crazy
- What y’alls out here? Hoopin?
- Yeah, playing HORSE, man
- Yeah? Who’s winning?
- Me
- Alright, so this dunk everybody’s talking about, let me see it
Let’s get up
- Easy!
- Have you ever dunked it?
- Relax!
- You got home-court advantage, start it off
- Want me to start it off?
- You start it off
- Alright
- Come on, man
- You can use your elbow
- Get up, C
Yup, I get it
Get in
Come on, man
I got that, I told you
- You’re a lot smaller on 2K
- I’m a lot smaller on 2K? What you mean by that, though?
- Goood!
- It’s gotta be all net
- Damnit!
Damn!
What's the wind doing?
Game time!
Good game, man
I can’t imagine, just not being able to come back
- Like this, just like that, or, like, behind the back
- And I learned this one from you, back in the day with the Clippers
- Ahhhhh
- So I was playing basketball with Dad, and Chris Paul pulled up
And working with him on dribbling, like getting past the defender
And basically talking me through how to get around people
When they’re trying to defend my right side
- I appreciate y’all having me out here, man, I’m serious
It’s probably more exciting for me than it is for y’all
- I don’t know about that
- Uh, seriously, I know, like, your story went viral and all that stuff like that
But to come out here and see y’all out here playing like this
This has got to me the coolest thing, man
- Thank you so much
- Make sure to give your family my best too, man
- I will
- I have to go back to school and be like, “Yo, I just met Chris Paul!”
And they'll be like, “Shut up!”
I’m like, “OK, you’ll see”
- Yo, wassup, man? I’m here in Iowa, right?
- Washington
And just beat somebody in HORSE
Don’t lie!
Y’all going to see the footage later, y’all going to see the footage
I won, all day everyday
- This is Carmelo Anthony, thanks for watching
To meet more heroes
Go to: Breal.Bleacherreport.com